des civils fuyant par centaines la ville
de cramât torse qu elle serait la
prochaine cible des russes à l'est de
l'ukraine
les dernières rumeurs que nous entendons
qui proviennent de sources officielles
sont que la russie deux des places se
trouve vers l'est et que les saumons
cela pourrait devenir un second mario
politi
car la ville de cramât torse qui se
trouve entre donetsk et un zoom deux
villes conquises par les russes dans
cette région deux autres sont encore
tenus par les ukrainiens kharkiv au nord
et mario paul au sud mais l'armée russe
avance et une attaque massive est
redoutée dans les jours qui viennent
alors les autorités ukrainiennes
conseils aux résidents de s'enfuir vers
l'ouest au plus vite je
les gens doivent quitter la région pour
que les forces armées ukrainiennes
puisse agir de manière plus efficace
comment est protégé la région de donetsk
est de l'ukraine
dans son ensemble
selon le pentagone les deux tiers des
forces russes qui occupaient la région
de kiev depuis le début de l'invasion se
sont repliés en biélorussie une
réorganisation des troupes avant un
nouvel assaut probablement dont le
dombass